hey hey out there what's going on
welcome welcome welcome welcome
to another another fed day version of
Market takes uh thank you so much for
being with us I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me on fed day where would you
rather be and that's even including some
of y'all watching this a little later I
know not everybody watches with us live
I appreciate you too but those of you
watching with us live right now 4 P.M
Eastern here on Market takes I
appreciate you the most so I am Dion
rabone reporter for the Wall Street
Journal this is Market takes today we
are breaking down opening up getting
deep inside the fomc meeting statement
of course the FED chairs press
conference that just ended right around
45 minutes ago we are going to get into
all that and talk about what it means in
light of this banking collapse this bank
run this questions about the systemic
fragility of the U.S banking system you
know I got y'all that's what we do here
on Market take so of course course like
I said we'll be talking through the
fed's rate decision today how that
aligned with expectations and why
expectations were what they were we're
going to talk about what the summary of
economic projection showed I think that
was pretty important today
um and really what the market is taking
away from this obviously we're going to
talk about the environment coming into
today's meeting uh how that has been
shifted by these questions about the
banking sector and of course checking on
the markets you know we always have to
do that we are going to also break down
the Powell press conference we're going
to talk about what the chairman said
what he didn't say what some of those
things mean and kind of read a little in
between the lines and then of course you
know we're going to talk about what
comes next because we are always looking
forward even though the data that we get
is backward looking although today with
the FED statement and the FED decision
that's all happening today markets are
reacting today in a major way we know
that so we're going to get into all of
that so listen without any further Ado
let's talk about what happened today
let's talk about what was announced the
fed the fomc the Federal Open markets
come committee announcing a 25 basis
point increase in the FED funds rate and
the effective fed funds rate want to
throw this chart up here on your screen
just to give you some context of what
we're looking at so where you see at the
right of your screen that's where we are
that line that basically goes just
straight up that's what the FED has done
since March 2022 raising the FED funds
rate sometimes by 75 basis points 50
basis points and today another 25 basis
point increase them so they're slowing
down the rate of increases and we are
still now but if you look back there
we're at the highest level that we've
been since 2008 2008 when weight started
coming down as a result of the global
financial crisis the early days things
like Lehman Brothers bear Stearns had
failed and so you were seeing the FED
start to say uh oh we need to start
lowering rates well now we're getting
them back up to that level again to try
and fight the inflation that we have
seen in the economy also important to
note as you see there where we are is
unusual rates had been lower near zero
as you see rates rolling along that zero
lower bound as it's called for most of
this century
we're start we are going to start If the
Fed actually raises rates to what the
level that they say they plan to we're
going to get up to the highest level
we've been since back around 2000 2001
when we hit that 2001 recession
um it's interesting that rates tend to
get higher around these recession levels
and then down when you get lower below
that that's when things start to get
better we now could be getting into some
of that you know some of those economic
worries that folks have had so just
wanted to put that up there to
illustrate where we are right now and
how that compares to the environment
that we had seen over the course the
last 20 years this is a very unusual
environment and when you look at that
fed that effective fed funds rate chart
you can see just how unusual it is so
another thing I want to talk about is
the fomc the statement today because the
decision to raise rates by 25 basis
points was was accompanied by a
statement and it was also accompanied by
a press conference from the chairman a
really interesting change is made to the
statement the FED usually doesn't like
to change things too much they change
the date they change who voted shout out
to our our departed colleague Leo
Brainerd the vice chair of the FED now
moved on to work in the government under
President Joe Biden but she was
certainly a very influential person no
longer with the FED now working with
President Biden and the government but
we salute Fed chair our former Vice
chair leielle Brainerd anyway want to
talk about the statement though
um very interesting pieces because the
FED took out a statement saying job
gains have been robust they say instead
picked up in recent months saying
meaning essentially that job growth is
even more than robust it's picked up
they took out a the reference to
inflation has eased somewhat and just
now it says inflation remains elevated
this is the Fed really saying jobs
picking up inflation remains elevated
saying they're more worried about
inflation they continue to worry about
the growth of the economy that's not the
dovish rate hike that a lot of people
have been talking about I think that's
why you're saying some of what you're
seeing in markets we will get into that
don't worry also all the references to
Russia's war against Ukraine which had
been in the second paragraph of the
statement removed cut out now it starts
with the U.S banking system is sound and
resilient first sentence in the second
paragraph recent developments are likely
to result in tighter credit conditions
for households and businesses and to
weigh on economic activity hiring and
inflation the extent of these of these
effects is uncertain the committee
remains highly attentive to inflation
risks what that tells you is the
committee is now saying all right we're
not worried as much about Russia Ukraine
all that inflation now we're worried
about this banking system which could
urge us to lower it I think that may be
why as soon as the statement was
released you saw the stock market jump
up you saw stocks jump higher and then
as the as the folks were reading through
this the algorithms really reacted
immediately to that but as real Traders
as humans came back to their computers
and started making moves you saw a
reaction to the rest of the statement
those were the big important changes in
the statement so definitely keep your
eye on that this banking system thing is
something the FED is keeping watch on
but that's the second paragraph remember
the first paragraph the FED talks about
inflation as job growth has picked up
and inflation remains elevated not has
these somewhat we're taking that out
inflation remains elevated that's big
and that's a big piece of why I think
the Market's doing what it's doing let's
also talk about how the the fed's
balance sheet has changed and what's
been happening because as a result of
this banking issue I don't want to call
it a banking crisis or a bank run but as
a result of some of these issues with
the banks the FED has made Moves so on
the one hand they're saying okay we're
watching this on the other hand I want
to throw something up here on your
screen just to show you some of the
actions that the FED has been taking
because a lot of this is about words but
it's also about actions and so just want
to put this chart up here at the fed's
balance sheet on your screen now what
you see is just that parabolic rise from
2020. fed's balance sheet just goes up
and up and up that's what they called QE
or what I guess we in the media called
QE Infinity where the FED said we will
buy as many bonds as necessary they
ratcheted that balance sheet up and up
and up and up
to levels it had never reached before I
had never even been close to before
we're always in unprecedented territory
and you got to the balance sheet being
about nine trillion dollars as in the
FED had bought nine trillion dollars
worth of bonds and and other things some
of them being uh bonds from junk rated
companies some being big companies like
apple Verizon things like that the Fed
was basically buying anything could get
its hands on and you saw that rise all
the way up to about nine trillion
dollars in the fed's balance sheet that
was money they were pumping out in the
economy by buying these bonds and then
you see that number that kind of it
starts to come down there and then at
the very right edge of your screen you
see that big tick up that just straight
line that was last week and that's what
the FED did in response to this banking
issue that's almost 300 billion dollars
the FED added to its balance sheet and
that is huge now that's more than the
week after Lehman Brothers collapsed in
October 2008 even when accounting for
inflation so even when you factor in
inflation the FED did more last week
than they did after Lehman Brothers
collapsed even though we're talking
about what they're saying is a far less
worrisome situation so keep that in mind
now I just want to throw that up there
to illustrate just how big and how
substantial the fed's response to that
banking crisis the issues with Silicon
Valley Bank Signature Bank and others
this work worries about First Republic
and all those things had been the Fed
was clearly worried they injected a lot
of money into the system that's a lot of
money that goes out into the economy at
least hypothetically when the fed's
doing all of these things adding to its
balance sheet they say we're doing this
because we're trying to support and
uplift the economy well as they're
trying to rein in the economy raise
rates to kind of lower inflation they
also just pumped about 300 billion
dollars which is kind of doing the
opposite of what they had talked about
now Fed chair Jerome Powell was asked
about this during the press conference
he kind of said oh this is different but
listen they're buying bonds they're
pumping money into the economy they're
pushing money into the banking system
which is exactly what they said they
were doing to help offset some of the
issues from the economic crisis at a
2008 in 2020 and in the years that
followed that when you see that balance
sheet just go up and up and up so this
is important to watch out for now let's
talk about the FED summary of economic
projections or how the FED sees the
economy what I want to throw up here is
the so-called Dot Plot these are fomc
members quote unquote assessments of the
economy just want to put this up on your
screen this is the December Dot Plot of
fomc members and as you can see there
it's it's right around 5.1 percent there
wasn't a big change from December which
is about three months ago their last
meeting when they did the Dot Plot today
but you see uh numbers hovering around
for 2023 expecting rates to be about 5.1
percent a few lower more than a few
higher but all in all the the
expectations 5.1 points 5.1 percent now
let's throw up the March summary of
economic projections The Dot Plot this
is March now you see it's it's very
similar but a little different in that
you see there are a couple dots moved
higher no one's moved lower there's in
fact less dots than you see there under
that five percent level than there were
in December right there's just that one
dot under five percent everyone expects
rates to be at least five percent a
couple people have raised their
expectations above five and a half
percent and now there's even one there's
that one more dot even higher almost at
that six percent level so want to put
that up just to illustrate that this was
not a hike where the FED said okay we're
hiking because we have to but we think
really things are going to go easy and
smooth as we move forward in the future
no no no the FED is saying we still
think we have to do more and that has a
lot to do with the data that we've seen
and that has a lot to do with the
environment we saw coming into this
report so let's talk about that the
environment we saw coming into today's
meeting and to and to today's decision
to raise rates by 25 basis points
because we know why they did that first
of all CPI and PPI that's a consumer
price index and the producer price index
what individuals you and I are paying
when we go to the store and what
businesses are paying for their goods
those have been coming down consistently
declining uh for about the past six
seven eight months now we've seen those
Decline and we've seen also the outsized
role of shelter AKA housing AKA rent
prices and home prices that's been
holding it up even though the fed's
real-time indicators have shown that
that's declining fed share Powell
mentioned that today in the press
conference he says we know that new
leases are being signed at a at the pace
of inflation in leases and in rents is
coming down we've seen that even though
in CPI and in PPI it's keeping it
staying elevated remember if you watch
Market takes when we did CPI
at our last uh this was last week on I
believe the 15th of March uh we talked
about the outsized role that shelter AKA
housing was playing and we know that
this is a lagging indicator it takes a
long time for this to get factored into
the reports and so when you're seeing
shelter holding up CPI well you can
assume and it's probably safe to assume
that CPI is actually lower than what
we're seeing in some of those numbers
and ppi is lower than what we're seeing
even though it plays a much smaller part
so with CPI being lower in inflation for
consumers overall being lower that's
good news for fed it says that they can
slow down we also have seen that over
the course of this time Services
inflation has been picking up well Goods
inflation which drove a big part of the
increase in inflation over the past
couple years or so as as we've been in
this pandemic environment or
post-pandemic environment Goods prices
have been picking up well they've come
down considerably but now Services
prices are coming up as in what you pay
when you go to the doctor what's your
pay and when you're going out to the bar
restaurants when you go see a specialist
for some medicine or when you just go to
the amusement park all those things are
Services rather than Goods those are
things that you buy on Amazon or when
you go to the store those prices are
rising even while Goods prices are
declining and that's what the FED is
concerned about fed share Jerome Powell
uh spotlighted that today
one thing to worry about with that as
well has been the jobs reports jobs have
been growing at a very fast pace and we
have not seen the sort of moderation or
decline in pickup and jobs growth that
the FED wants to see the FED wants to
see it is said in its summary of
economic projections it expects
unemployment to rise about one percent
that means millions of people lose their
jobs they also want to see fewer job
openings and what we saw in the jolts
report the job opening and labor
turnover survey was there have been
fewer jobs job openings added as and
people are posting fewer jobs looking
for employees than they had previously
that has come down a little bit but not
a lot and we're still seeing that at a
very high rate so all those things
support kind of the FED moving taking
his foot off the brake and sort of
slowing down doing a little bit less on
the other side of that we do have the
China reopening we have that Services
increase in prices that we've seen and
that affects a lot more of the economy
because the US is a mostly service-based
economies of economy excuse me unlike
other places like Germany China Etc that
are still based on exporting Goods
you've got also with China reopening
you've got a number of other countries
seeing inflation pick up France
inflation or inflation in France Rose to
6.2 in February up from January
inflation in Japan Rose to 4.4 up from
in January and the UK inflation is still
double digits and the Eurozone inflation
fell just a little bit from 8.6 to 8.5
percent what's that telling us that's
saying that all over the world inflation
is still either picking up or coming
down just a little bit and that impacts
us because this is a global economy no
economy exists in a vacuum everything
happens with relation to other economies
all those things are worrisome also we
saw those existing home sales the report
that came out earlier this week showed
existing home sales up 14 and a half
percent that's the thing the fed's
policy can have the most direct impact
on and it's showing that existing home
sales spiked up after coming down
consistently for a number of months
housing starts also up by about 10 this
shows the FED is not slowing demand
that's got to be something they're
worried about and that could be why we
saw what I think is a hawkish rate hike
this this month from the Fed so keep
that in mind on the other side of that
also of course oil and gas prices have
been coming lower natural gas has been
just jumping off a cliff price wise and
that means that you're seeing different
forces kind of converging and we're
going to see which one breaks out
now consistent inflation has
consistently moved lower in recent
months but we've also seen this banking
crisis that could be evidence that
things are breaking within the economy
and the FED needs to slow down I'm
seeing a lot of folks economists Market
Watchers Etc in my inbox saying Dion the
FED is making a mistake they need to
slow down they need to stop raising
rates they need to reevaluate what
they're doing that's all because and not
all because actually I should say that
case has been increased or you know
folks have pointed to this and said this
is evidence that the FED needs to slow
down and stop because the problems in
banking are going to hurt businesses
especially small and mid-sized
businesses that rely on banks these big
companies they go out in the markets and
they can borrow money there but these
small and medium businesses that need
Banks Banks are going to pull back
because of this there's a lot of worry
about what banks are doing and not
billing out and lending and that's going
to hurt businesses that's going to hurt
mom and pop and that's going to hit
people right in their pocketbooks really
quickly want to check in on the markets
real fast we've got the Dow and the s p
and the Nasdaq all down down
significantly down about 1.6 percent
each index is hovering right around that
level we saw a huge nosedive in stock
prices and I think that's because of
this hawkishness that we're seeing from
the FED fed saying they can basically
they're not prepared to back off what
they were doing the market could be
thinking one of two things one could be
that the FED isn't seeing the force for
the trees if they're not understanding
What's Happening Here in the market that
they're making a huge mistake the other
possibility is that they see okay the
FED is determined to get inflation down
and so we are seeing these these moves
in inflation the ones we talked about
price prices moving higher on Services
uh things like job increases continuing
and they've seen okay the FED is going
to get back to doing what it was doing
when we were worried now it's time to
sell stocks it's time to get out of risk
it's time to move things lower because
the FED is going to be back on its horse
making moves taking action and that's
not going to be good for stocks it could
be either one of those we're seeing the
same move in the bond market you're
saying bond prices move higher which
means those yields are falling lower
really across the board the sixth month
is up about five basis points today in
price uh down about five base points
excuse me in yield the tenure is down
about 14 basis points in yield these are
some pretty significant moves five year
and the three year down about 23 basis
points in terms of the yield there also
let's check out uh crude Futures I think
is really interesting Brent crude is
down about one percent uh WTI is up
about half percent very interesting but
gold and silver are up huge that shows
you that the market is worried about
recession we're seeing gold up about 1.8
percent almost two percent silver up
almost three percent those are generally
worries about recession and that's what
we could be seeing here from the market
also very important don't want to skip
out currencies the euro is up big on the
dollar but that movie has come down
significantly if the dollar in the Euro
ended about parity today or the dollar
ends up Rising that could be a
significant notification to the rest of
the market that their real worries about
recession and about the fate and about
the path for growth moving forward all
right listen uh we were going to talk a
little bit about the power press
conference but I think I talked about
that Fed chair Jerome Powell highlighted
again super core inflation that's that
Services X housing or core Services X
housing really a particular measure
that's still rising and the FED has said
our eyes are still on that and I think
that was a signal to the market things
haven't changed the FED is still doing
what it's doing maybe we shouldn't have
gotten all excited over these past few
days what comes next well we've got new
home sales tomorrow this existing home
sales report was bad if you're worried
about inflation because it shows that
people are not deterred by mortgage
rates where they are single family and
multi-family homes picked up in this
last report that report was all bad for
inflation this next report new home
sales that's out tomorrow on Thursday
that's going to give you a big signal on
whether or not the fed's uh the fed's
rate hikes are having an impact on the
overall housing market maybe new home
sales turned down existing home sales
are about 85 to 90 of the market so that
was the big report but new home sales
would kind of either bring that home or
refute that because we also saw it with
housing starts also the FED discount
window borrowing numbers are out
tomorrow we're going to get an update on
that that's where we saw this big almost
300 billion dollar increase from last
week we checked that on Thursday it's
coming out tomorrow be sure and check
that out that's going to tell you how
much more banks are taking advantage of
the fed's money also flash pmis on
Manufacturing Services out Friday the
latest update on the economy and how
businesses see it and of course next
week we'll have pending home sales on
Wednesday University of Michigan
consumer sentiment on Friday and New
York fed President John Williams will
talk about how he's seeing the economy
he's a very close Confidant of Fed chair
Jerome Powell and we know that when when
John Williams is talking he's speaking
what the FED is thinking very important
to check out what he's saying listen we
went a little long today here on Market
takes but those of y'all that stuck with
me that are still with me here I
appreciate you being here I know you
could have tuned at any time gone
anywhere else in the world but you're
stuck here with me and I appreciate that
look thanks for being with us so much on
Market takes and we will see you next
time